representative cahill
can't hear you michael yes uh home alone
in the room thank you
thank you representative abellini
present at work employees around
representative nunes
good morning i'm present i'm home alone
in pelham
representative baruti um my home office
in manchester
i'm alone for now but people will be
coming
representative schmidt i am alone in my
office in nashua
representative boyd at home alone in my
office
representative bouchard i'm home alone
in manchester
representative toomey home alone in
nashua
representative susie president home
alone
representative warden good morning home
in my office in manchester nobody else
here
representative turcotte for cut here in
the lobby
representative seaworth
representative seaworth here in the lb
representative sullivan representative
sullivan here in the lld
program representative callum
here in the llb all right looks like we
have everyone here did i miss anyone
there's linda oh and representative
doucet
representative uh trout
see him either chairman i can reach out
to him i wasn't aware that he was
supposed to come so perhaps he did get
an invitation
is who are we expecting representative
prout
um yeah we're going to party remember
this to me
oh i thought you said proud i'm sorry my
apologies
anyone else unaccounted for that i did
not say
thank you
chris christina do we have the assistant
commissioner with us here
mr labors is on
ladies and gentlemen as you aware we
scheduled this meeting at 10 30 uh this
morning to talk to
the department of labor um excuse me
employment securities
there have been some questions that some
of you have had that you've emailed
around to the committee
regarding questions people have had
obviously there's a lot of new rules a
lot of government rules that are put in
through the care act
programs um and there's a lot of things
going on so we wanted representative
excuse me uh assistant fischer levers
to be able to outline what they're doing
what's been going on and then have this
committee offer any
questions of the commissioner as well as
members of the public understanding that
at no time should we be getting involved
in anyone's particular case you can talk
about
possibly a an issue um
but not anyone's individual case nor can
anyone of the public come in
um and ask specifically about their case
to the commissioner that's a generic
question about
procedure we're all ready to
rock and roll
see no questions there's a
representative proud has joined us
um assistant commissioner lavers thank
you very much for
joining us appreciate your time and a
very busy man
um i think i i know i see you all the
time on television and everything else
so i know you you're out there
whenever possible so please if you
wouldn't mind giving us an update
on some of the things that your
department has been
going through the past year or so
absolutely um first first of all mr
chairman can you hear me okay
yeah all right um it's good to see
everybody
i had a few quick slides that i thought
i could go over and share
um just showing where we're at with
claim volume and what the trust fund is
currently doing
and then i can talk briefly about
overpayments
and appeals and then do my best to
answer
all of the questions uh from any of the
members so
i'll quickly uh share my screen with a
couple of slides
there we go this is mr commissioner um
we've
allotted an hour and a half uh we don't
have to use the entire hour and a half
but i don't want you to feel you're
rushed either so
okay thank you
all right this shouldn't take too long
these are um
uh this is from um or similar to a
presentation that
uh brian gottlob and i had done earlier
this week for
senate uh ways and means and this is
just the
portion of the presentation that looks
at claim volume
and trust fund so um this first slide
that
folks are seeing is uh shows you monthly
initial claim numbers just giving some
perspective on
what we have experienced uh during
the pandemic and comparing that back to
the great recession and i say comparing
that back to the great recession you
really can't
compare them um neither with the speed
with which
uh the claims increased during the
pandemic and
the heights that they reached during the
pandemic
they're really uh the they're really um
apples and oranges um when you look at
them um and
and what we've been tasked uh with doing
uh you see on that right hand side of
your screen with that
um dramatic spike um in those monthly
numbers compared to
back during the great recession when we
look at the weekly claims
um so on this slide these are the weekly
claim filers so people that
file a weekly claim in order to trigger
a payment of unemployment benefits
you see on the left-hand side of your
screen where we were
the week prior to the
emergency order from governor sununu
expanding eligibility
in a few weeks prior to the federal
government expanding eligibility with
the cares act so march 14th 2020 we were
just under 4 000 weekly claims
um that was uh where we had been for
quite some time uh with
uh with you know having experienced um
the longest period of recovery
in our history with the growth from the
great recession
and then quickly things took a different
turn
we saw our claim volume spiking through
march and april and then we
peaked um with the week ending may 2nd
you see where we were just under 117
000 weekly filers so that is the single
largest week ever in the history of new
hampshire's unemployment program
those numbers then fell
through last summer and
the fall then started to go up again
with the spike and covet cases uh with
late
fall and into the winter and then we
started 2021
um with just over 45 000
weekly filers um so a far cry
from where we were at the height of the
pandemic but
as you can see um you know
about 10 times where we were prior to
the pandemic
looking uh to as current as we can get
with our numbers
that we have from the bureau of labor
statistics um we are at 364
29 uh with the week of april 17th
um something important to be said here
um
uh is the inside the numbers um and all
of the different
programs that are part of each of these
so
obviously with the um the pre-pandemic
number of 3909 that was all
state ui right because that was our only
program
that we had available to individuals for
accessing unemployment benefits
um then as we get into the pandemic
numbers these are a blend of programs so
it's both
state ui for those people that qualify
for regular state unemployment benefits
meaning they had
sufficient earnings in their four
quarter base period and they had
a qualifying separation that was
determined not to be the fault
of the individual so the most common
situation there
is some type of layoff but also we have
the federal cares act programs for
you have the pandemic unemployment
assistance program
that's the program that's created
benefits for self-employed
for gig workers and for individuals that
need to remove themselves
from the labor force due to a pandemic
reason for which eligibility
was created under the cares act so those
are folks that
could be dealing with covet themselves
could be caring for someone in the
household
that has coveted prior to schools
being required to be back offering
in-person learning that could have been
apparent
with a remote learner um and they are
unable to work as a result of the school
being closed
could be someone that is
self-quarantined
at the advice of their health care
provider so that would be someone with
an underlying medical condition that
their
their medical professional has said um
should not
be going into a work environment um and
um the self-employed and gig workers
like i had mentioned
and then lastly the federal extension as
well
so people that have exhausted their
state ui
they transition into the pandemic
emergency unemployment compensation
program
or p-e-u-c and
so when we look at a week of april 17th
2021 that 36425
429 includes all of those programs
um that breakdown is about uh
19 000 people out of that 36
000 are in state ui and the balance
of them are in either pua which is right
around
9 000 so those are the people that are
either self or self-employed
a gig worker or remove themselves from
the labor force
um and then the balance of that is
people who have exhausted state ui
and are in the federal extension now um
as we'll see in the next slide with the
breakdown of dollars
everyone or two slides later so um not
to get ahead of myself
but everyone that's in any of those
programs also gets the extra 300
a week in that federal enhancement as
well and i'll show you a breakdown of
those dollars in a minute
this slide gives you a comparison
of how new hampshire stacks up against
the rest of the country
i mean we've called out our new england
neighbors so you can see where everyone
currently sits
but what we try to do here is give
people a real good sense of
the current state of the number of
people
filing for unemployment and either state
or federal programs as a percentage of
our pre-pandemic labor force
there's been a lot of unexplained
fluctuations in labor force numbers as
published by bls during the pandemic
they have admitted that their numbers
are less than reliable
um so what we have been doing is we've
been comparing
our numbers against our pre-pandemic
labor force number
in order to remove some of that
unexplainable fluctuation from bls
and as you can see here new hampshire in
the red we have the
lowest percentage of people filing for
unemployment benefits
in any of the programs either state or
federal
as a lowest in the northeast as a
percentage
of our pre-pandemic labor force just
under five percent
maine you can see is the closest to us
here in new england
uh massachusetts is the furthest away
from us here in new england
um at just over 15 percent
uh kind of grouped in a other states
that are having a
much more difficult time on getting
people back to work
and i'm going to go back to that prior
slide but i wanted to talk about this as
it makes more sense to talk about this
first
this is the dollar breakdown of the
money that has been paid out of the
unemployment system during the pandemic
so we've paid out just over 1.82
billion dollars in benefits that's more
than we paid out in the prior decade
this chart gives you a sense of where
those dollars have been sourced from
so that top line of f puck that's the
federal enhancement program so that was
the 600
enhancement back in 2020 that lasted
until july
and is currently set at three hundred
dollars a week that gets
added to everyone that qualifies for a
weekly benefit amount in either ui
pua or peuc they get that three hundred
dollars
that goes until september fourth under
the american rescue plan
we've paid out just over a billion
dollars in just that enhancement
um the red bar you see is from our state
trust fund
we have paid out just over 324 million
dollars in benefits
we started and i have a slide that will
show you where we currently are
but just to not build up suspense we are
currently at
104 million in our trust fund we started
the pandemic
at 300 million uh pua we've paid out
just over 321 million dollars in pua
um importantly all of the the blue lines
here are all federally sourced
and the only state trust fund source of
payments
is that redline i'm in ui payments
lwa we paid out 88 million dollars that
was
the lost wages assistance program that
added 300
a week to people's benefits for six
weeks back in
august and september of 2020 that was
done by presidential
memorandum at the time um and then
lastly the peuc so that's the federal
extension
we're looking at 58 and a half million
dollars
that has been paid out of that which is
uh federal as well
now going back to the slide that i
skipped over
with regard to trust fund solvency
right now we have 22 states that have
depleted their trust funds
there they have borrowed a total of 55
or just over 55 billion
dollars including 2.2 billion borrowed
by massachusetts
this is borrowing done in order for them
to pay weekly benefits
our trust fund remains solvent like i
said we are currently at 104 million
dollars
and we are forecasted to stay
solvent through 2021 in large measured
due
to the 50 million dollars that was
provided to the trust fund from
federal cares act money in the decision
made earlier by governor sununu
so the impact on employer tax rates that
employers have experienced so far during
the pandemic
the first impact that caused their rates
to go up was the loss of the fund
balance reductions
so that that's our statutory solvency
control
on the trust fund where when the fund
reaches 250 million employers
get a reduction in their rate of a half
point and then at 275 million they get a
full point reduction
and at 300 million they get a point and
a half reduction
um as the uh
claim roles increased as quickly and as
significantly as they did
and and the balance in the trust fund
fell as quickly as it did those
reductions
uh were quickly removed because the fund
was below that 250 million dollar mark
and as a result in the third and fourth
quarters of 2020 we had a half
point uh statutory surcharge on employer
tax rates
um we were able to remove that effective
with
the first quarter of 2021
we don't expect there to be any
surcharges
for the remaining quarters of 2021
and importantly we never
implemented the second half point
surcharge
um in statute so although
employer tax rates have gone up as a as
a result
of the loss of the fund balance
reductions
they are currently at at what i refer to
as neutral
um and they're paying at the rate that's
the result
of their experience they are not
um having an increased rate because of
the surcharges
uh those are not in play right now
um and again uh the the intent of
uh the money from the karzak flex fund
in order to avoid those surcharges
was so that we weren't creating a
disincentive
for employers to hire by creating by
making it more expensive
for them to bring on each additional
employee
so employers are at their true
experience rate
right now however their experience rate
is lower right now
than it would have been had there not
been
additional measures taken as a part of
the original emergency order that the
governor issued back in march of 2020.
so all of the benefits that we've paid
out that you
saw the breakdown by program normally
those that are paid out of the state ui
trust fund those would be charged
against
tax paying employers so when i refer to
their experience their experience
is both as positive and negative
pieces to that the positive being we
look at what they've paid in in taxes
the negative to the employer is that we
apply the benefits paid out to their
former employees
against their experience that has not
been
going on during the pandemic so during
the pandemic
all benefit charges have been direct
charge
to the fund rather than to
the experience rate of the tax-paying
employers
the result of that is going to be that
as employers see their
tax rate determinations that get issued
those go out every august
and then control your rate for
quarters three four one and two
those those determinations will not
have an increase in their experience
rate based on the benefits that have
been paid
out um that that's important for keeping
their rates down
and again that's been in place since
march of 2020 likewise we have not been
requiring non-profits to reimburse the
fund
uh dollar for dollar for benefits paid
out like they normally would
so reimbursing employers like our
hospitals and other nonprofits who
normally would have to reimburse the
fund dollar for dollar that has not been
taking place
as well so that 50 million from the
cares act covered
that as well so that no one is getting a
free ride
on the trust fund which was created by
the quarterly tax payments from
taxpaying employers but all those are
are measures that have had impact on
employer rates
and i think in large measure what we
have seen as rates have stayed
much lower than they could have
otherwise been
certainly and lower than uh was the
experience
from employers following the great
recession
when they were hit with both surcharges
when their experience was hit so their
experience rating was going up causing
an increase in their rates
so none of that has happened we continue
to stay solvent
and continue to forecast that we'll be
able to avoid
uh borrowing from the federal government
um and i think this is the last slide
and then we can get into overpayments
and
[Music]
appeals related questions this is our
updated forecast
this is from we have both
brian gottlob our director of our
economic and labor market information
bureau
and one of his economists they do
dueling forecasts
um so that we can um they do different
methods in their forecasting and that
helps us with uh
to control and see how each of them
are doing how close they are um our our
band
for where we expect to be finishing 2021
uh right now
is a balance between 65 to 84 million
in the trust fund and then improvements
although not
shown here but improvements going into
2022.
um so um the the fund stays
um relatively healthy compared to
everything that's going on what we have
experienced during the pandemic and
the experience of other states and what
they have seen so
fortunate in that regard that we're able
to start
with such a healthy trust fund and i'll
stop sharing
right there and i'll talk a little bit
about uh
overpayments and appeals as well
but first i'll i'll address appeals as
that's a little bit
not quite as complicated as overpayments
um
but appeals are a um
it's an it's an area that is difficult
to bring on
the expertise that you need in a quick
fashion i
um compare it to
a court that's that receives a decade's
worth
of cases in a short period of time
can't just go out and grab a bunch of
judges off the street to come in and
hear those
so it requires a certain amount of
knowledge
and a skill level that you can
conduct that type of hearing so what
we've what we've done
we have uh brought in uh we went from
ten
hearing off our from four hearing
officers rather to
ten hearing officers currently they are
all on the docket
they are hearing cases um we have issued
a
request for proposals out to new
hampshire law firms
in order to supplement our hearing
officers for new hampshire licensed
attorneys
to be able to conduct hearings and issue
decisions
we felt that was a better alternative
rather than
bringing in or trying to bring in and
skill up
other hearing officers that we're only
going to need for a short period of time
the efforts that we've uh done in
increasing our hearing officers
have really started to pay dividends uh
prior to the pandemic we were hearing
uh just under 200 cases per month
uh right now we have over 500 cases
scheduled
to be heard in uh this month in may
as well as june and because of the
additional resources we've brought on
that are going through
the correspondence that it's received in
appeals
um we have another 2500 appeals
that are able are ready to be scheduled
and are being added to the may
june and july dockets uh right now
so um we're going through our
our backlog that built up um i would say
over the course of the last month we're
going through it much faster
than we were because of some additional
resources we brought on from
the vendor that supports our
unemployment hotline
i took 20 of those people and i put them
on correspondence review
so we receive a lot of correspondence in
our appeals section
about 30 percent of it are actual
appeals so now i have
20 additional people going through that
they process about
32 300 pieces of correspondence a week
and so that backlog of correspondence is
coming down quickly
um that results in more cases being
scheduled
that's the 2500 that are being added to
the docket right now
and then um that will also probably
result in an increased number of higher
level administrative
appeals as well requests for reopening
cases to our appellate board
so we'll be prepared for that as well um
so those are our appeals numbers uh
right now where things stand
um with regard to overpayments um
overpayments in terms of how they get
treated by the department
um it depends on a host of factors uh
whether or not the individual was
determined to be at fault and causing it
whether or not the dollars for which are
overpaid are from a state program or a
federal program
so that all of that plays a role in
what is required to happen uh with
regard to an overpayment
so what we have for overpayment in terms
of number of people
and the dollar amounts for those that
are at fault so people that
um made an inaccurate
statement to the department on their
initial claim or their weekly claims
um or were not
truthful um in the information that they
provided and i can give you some
examples of what that looks like
we have about 18 million dollars in
overpayments uh to that group it's about
12 000 people
they have received determinations from
the department
if their overpayment is from the state
ui program
they are notified in that determination
that they are not at fault in the
creation of it or they are at fault
so these people would have been
determined that they were at fault
in creating the overpayment um and
that uh they are required to pay that
back
and so they then have the opportunity to
file an appeal uh they have the
opportunity to
um seek forgiveness or compromise
of that if it's a state overpayment
um and then if it's a federal
overpayment um
we actually um have to uh they the
individuals if they don't go through an
appeal they have to go through
a the waiver process that's set up by
the federal government um
so with those 12 000 that i just
discussed of individuals that are
determined to be at fault um in the
creation of the overpayment about 18
million dollars
so they would not be eligible
for a waiver they can request a waiver
but if they're ultimately at fault
the waiver uh requirements and the
federal
guidelines do not allow us to waive
those overpayments
so they need to be repaid and the the
examples of that
like i said it's based on inaccurate
um information provided to the
department so these are
the most common examples are individuals
who simply
misinformed the department with regards
to their separation when they originally
filed
so there were quite a few people
that weren't working at the time
uh prior to the time when they started
filing in fact they stopped working in
many instances uh back towards the end
of 19
or maybe they stopped working at the
very beginning of 2020.
when they filed with the department they
would have represented to the department
that they had a coronavirus related
separation
and that it was the pandemic as to why
they could not work
and come and find out that once we would
have received information
from the employer which in a lot of
cases was not provided timely because
the employers were dealing with their
own problems right at that time
um come to find out the individual would
have left employment
prior for a personal reason or to seek
other employment
um and was not unemployed because of the
pandemic
and therefore would have would have been
ineligible for
for benefits similar are those
uh the self-employed individuals that
became eligible during the pandemic
previously they had no eligibility for
unemployment
um and initially when we were trying to
set them up and get them into the
correct benefit amounts
we required affidavits from
self-employed individuals
that where they would provide us what
their earnings were
for the prior calendar year so what they
had earned in
2019 and that was an affidavit
and then subsequent to that we received
federal guidance saying that all
individuals needed to provide
documentation to substantiate
their self-employment and so
we then required those individuals in
most cases to provide their 2019
schedule c's
um in a lot of cases what came in on
their 2019 schedule c
uh was much lower than what they had
represented to the department in their
affidavit as to what their earnings were
the impact of that is that they would
have been set up at a higher weekly
benefit amount
as a result of their affidavit earnings
and then when we get their schedule c
showing much lower earnings or maybe
no earnings at all then
there is a gap in terms of what their
weekly benefit amount
should be and they would be found
overpaid
for that gap so um
those are um uh the the common um
scenarios in that 18 million uh that's
about
one percent of total benefits that have
been paid out
during the pandemic um i've
i understand uh where the focus lies on
some of on some of this
but um it it is important to note that
the department did get the dollars right
and the payments right in over 97
percent of the cases despite
having a decades worth of volume
and a decade's worth of payments i do
think the department deserves a lot of
credit for getting it right
um over 97 of the time
and then with these one percent of
people that
are now found overpaid that do have an
opportunity to appeal
and we're trying to get through those as
quickly as we can
um they they are
currently required to repay those
benefits and if they appeal then that
will be
delayed until that appeal decision um
gets issued now with the other with
other folks that are not
at fault in creating their overpayment
oh
of it one important point i forgot to
make their um
the program breakdown for that 18
million
as the same for the folks that are not
at fault
about 20 of those dollars are from the
state trust fund
so about eighty percent of overpayment
dollars are from a federal source
most of that sixty percent of it is from
the federal enhancement
um you know when that was six hundred
dollars a week and now three hundred
dollars a week
so eighty percent of the of the
overpayment dollars are federal
source dollars the other twenty percent
are sourced from the state trust fund
um getting to the
individuals who are not at fault
um in the creation of the overpayment so
it's it's in most cases
agency error we're dealing with about 8
000 people
about 25 million dollars so there are
some
instances where that is um attributed to
employer error
where we could have been provided with
inaccurate
earnings information but most of that i
don't want to misrepresent that
and suggest that that's um by large
measure employer error it's not
most of that is agency error and
so that's about 25 million dollars of
agency error so that individuals receive
money they should not have received that
they were not
eligible for um but um
through agency error they did
get eligibility determinations and they
did get paid
um now with regard to those types of
overpayments
if it is sourced from state ui the
individual is notified right in the
determination
saying hey you're not at fault in the
creation of this overpayment you don't
have to pay it back
okay we do that by state statute in
terms of
and rule on fault federal
overpayments states are not allowed to
waive
or forgive the overpayment in that
initial
determination the state is required to
follow federal waiver procedures where
we actually have to look at each case
individually first we have to look to
see whether or not they are at fault or
not
if they are not at fault we can proceed
to the second prong
of the federal waiver test which
requires us to look at their financial
circumstances
and to determine whether or not
repayment
would create a financial burden on the
individual
so that is not something that can happen
in that initial determination because we
don't
have a financial affidavit yet from the
individual
so those individuals that are not at
fault in the creation of the overpayment
they receive instruction
on how to go about requesting a waiver
that we have a form available to them on
our website
along with the financial affidavit they
are then required to submit both of
those to the department
and then we look at that to make sure
that they meet that federal standard
so it's a it's a time intensive process
on on those waivers i would prefer to
deal with
those waivers in a blanket fashion
but u.s department of labor has come
back to states and says wheat and said
we cannot
do that we have to look at them one by
one
so we are doing that right now our legal
section is processing
these waiver requests and we're moving
through them
as as quickly as we can right now and
individuals as they receive those
notices
they get the instruction on going to the
uh
the appeal route or going through the
waiver route
um and um we'll be
issuing those decisions as quickly as we
can on waivers
um so that's uh so all in all like i
said
in over 97 percent of payments
um they were paid correctly to the right
people
uh to eligible people in the right
amount about one percent of payments
were paid as a result of the department
being provided inaccurate and misleading
information
in most cases unless that's reversed on
appeal
those people will have to pay those
dollars back and then
in about one and a half percent of those
payments
those people were paid they shouldn't
have been paid
it's the department's fault and either
they are told in the determination that
they don't have to pay it back if it's
state ui
and then if it's a federal source
payment they are then given instruction
on how to go about requesting a waiver i
would expect
in those cases where the person is not
at fault
as long as they complete the form and
they complete the financial affidavit
i suspect that in the overwhelming
majority of those cases
that the waiver is going to be granted
but again we have to do those
individually
and i'll i'll stop there i know that's a
lot of information
um so i'll try not to keep on going
on this topic but mr chairman if the i'd
like to
obviously i'll stick around for as long
as you need me to answer questions
thank you commissioner um we do
recognize that you got 97
of this right you were criticized for
not paying quick enough and now you're
going to be criticized for if you paid
made a mistake that you uh
are asking for your money back so um
what's the uh
expression a good no good deed goes
unpunished so
we do appreciate that obviously this is
very complex
and um people have a lot of questions
and
and you know don't understand things so
i have a number of questions but i want
to open it up to
uh the members um first
are there any hints or any questions
here within the lob
at first representative seaworth
followed by representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman and i want to
follow up on something you said
obviously what you talked about is
addressing
the concern from the state side of it
but if
a constituent is going to be their
biggest concern
is if they were delayed in getting
payment or otherwise
had a problem on that end
[Music]
do you have kind of an overview
the squeaky wheel that's the only thing
i heard about but do you have an
overview statistically
of what happened in terms
of delays in the normal processing where
people who file might have seen
uh extraordinary circumstances
in the time it took to get payment
yeah thank you representative i i would
i'd compare new hampshire's record
of timeliness and payment against any
other state
as chairman infantine had pointed out
the criticism early on was
not getting the dollars out fast enough
even though we were exceeding um
our timeliness in terms of how quickly
we got dollars out
as compared to the great recession even
though
our claim loads were um
in most instances quadruple quintuple
um that which we were seeing in the
great recession so i
so i think depending on the
circumstances of someone's claim
really dictates how long it takes if
they have a complicated
claim with a big payout from their
employer that needs to be
factored in by someone looking at their
claim and making sure that they don't
get paid
uh too much or are too early because of
that payout or they have complicated
uh circumstances of their separation
those types of claims always take a
little bit longer
but in a lot of in a lot of these cases
with the particular with the agency
error overpayments and the 25 million
that's because we paid too fast
we we you know in hindsight if um i'd
held on to those claims for those 8 000
claims for a few more weeks for another
month and a half or so maybe i would
have been
had the information i needed from their
employer to determine that they weren't
eligible
um but you know we were under a lot of
pressure to
issue payments quickly and that's what
we did with the best
information we had available at the time
knowing what
people were dealing with during the
early stages
of the pandemic right now with the
people that are filing like i
pointed out before we have both 34 35
000 people that are filing right now
in terms of timing i just had i looked
at a
claim uh two weeks ago a very
complicated claim someone who had been
filing during
the early stages of the pandemic went
back to work uh complicated reason for
not
continuing to work had a big pay up from
that employer
had part-time earnings as they came back
and when they came back we had them back
in pace status within two weeks
um that's pretty good um considering
uh that we're still dealing with uh
volume
uh that's you know nine times that which
we had
prior to the pandemic so um you know
we've we've looked at timeliness
compared
for the early stages of the pandemic
compared to the great recession we know
we paid faster
uh the fact that we had 25 million
dollars in agency error overpayments
that shows you that we were we were
paying a little bit too fast
in some cases um i do uh i
i do think that when you look at total
payments made by states
um and the percentage of improper
payments or overpayments that we got
wrong
when you compare new hampshire against
anybody else and we and you can see that
we got
97.6 uh percent of those dollars correct
i think that will stand up well against
anybody else
i would caution against looking at some
of the
reports that are available from u.s
department of labor right now
um most of those are inaccurate uh
and itself uh you know they'll admit
that those are inaccurate because
the the reporting mechanisms that those
reports were based off
in all states had those shut off
intermittently throughout 2020
so those are not accurate portrayals of
how quickly appeals are being dealt with
or how quickly payments are going out
thank you representative sullivan
followed by representative cahill
good to see you deputy commissioner
the uh could you explain what the
financial guidelines are for the federal
waivers
what what determines whether somebody
gets the waiver or not
so the um there's not a a time deadline
for the waiver itself so when someone
receives a determination
that includes an overpayment from one of
the federal programs they have
they have language in there i'm
explaining them the waiver process we
have it on our website
so there's not unlike an appeal an
appeal
someone has to file that appeal within
14 days of their determination
with a waiver there's not a time limit
the standard
that is in place for considering those
waivers
and determines whether the state can
grant it or reject it
first we have to determine whether the
individual is at fault
in creation of the overpayment the
second prong if the person is not
at fault we then look at their financial
circumstances
and if repayment would create a
financial hardship
we are allowed to grant it if
the person made
payments and decisions based on having
received those benefits that they
wouldn't have otherwise done had they
not received those benefits
that's another grounds for finding that
they meet the financial
uh part of the test and then
uh the last uh prong of that test is
whether
uh um repayment would be unconscionable
um not really any definition around that
um
states are left to implement it
as they see as they see fit but again
i think as long as someone is not at
fault
i'm hard pressed to think of a scenario
that they would not
also meet the financial burden portion
of that standard
i'm not quite sure i understand what the
what you would have to see in someone's
financial affidavit to determine that
they
would not uh um be financially uh harmed
by
making repayment they have to be
here or what what what's the criteria
well you know we have to we have to know
their financial circumstances
okay that's uh been clearly required by
the feds and the guidance that they've
issued
so we accomplished that by obtaining a
financial affidavit which
is in the world of financial affidavits
it's a pretty short one
this is a two-page financial affidavit
where we look at household revenue
and income coming in we look at
household assets and then we look at
household expenses
um so the first thing we do is we
compare monthly
income against monthly expenses um
that's our first
uh review to see whether or not we can
grant the
the waiver then secondarily
we look to see whether the person has
described any decisions that they've
made as a result of receiving benefits
that um they wouldn't have otherwise
done if they hadn't received them maybe
they
paid a large amount of credit card debt
maybe they paid off
um a they paid a semester of college
tuition for one of their children
differently
than they would have otherwise done
those types of circumstances are looked
at that would be grounds
for someone meeting that financial
test and then the last provision being
repayment would be unconscionable um you
know i'm careful in how this gets
applied because you know some people
just because you're you might be in good
financial condition
i don't think that should require you to
pay back a benefit that was paid to you
as a result of the agency screwing up
and so just because you might have more
income than someone else i don't think
that should be grounds for denial and it
won't be in how new hampshire implements
it
but we look at all um all
portions of that spectrum so we look at
whether you know it's going to create
financial hardship and having to pay it
back we look at whether or not you made
decisions that
in reliance upon receipt of those
dollars that you wouldn't have otherwise
made
and then that catch-all at the end
whether or not repayment would be
unconscionable
it's not our test right it's the it's
the federal test
we're required to implement it prior to
forgiving repayment of those
overpayments from federally sourced
programs
i would rather be able to waive it right
in that initial determination like we do
with state ui
but if we do that we've already been
told that it would be
held to be out of compliance with the
feds and we would not be doing those
people any favors because we
we would then be subject on audit to
having to go back
and have the people go through the
correct process stephen one more
question
yes but yes okay i guess based on the
third criteria
um i would suggest that all between that
would be unconscionable
so um provide waivers to everyone um
representative you and i are on the on
the same page uh there was uh the state
of texas tried doing that
uh following one of their um
because these federal programs are based
on federal disaster unemployment
texas had several recent disasters that
required payments under their under
federal disaster
unemployment assistance programs they
tried doing that
on on one of the instances and and tried
saying that
by very nature of someone needing
unemployment
that they are just assumed to have met
the financial burden
um and they granted the waivers to
everyone um
the feds used that as an example of what
states are
not allowed to do in kind of their shot
across the bow
when they put out their guidance on on
issuing waivers
um one more question of the 25 million
um
that was uh uh not the fault of the uh
recipient how much of that was federal
and how much of the state
yeah so that's a it's a 80 20 split
there so 80 percent
is from a federal source 20 20 of that
is from the state so we're looking at
about five million dollars
uh from that total that would be um
that would have come from the state
trust fund
thank you representative cahill thank
you mr chairman and thank you mr lavers
uh
over this period you and i have had many
correspondences and
conversations and uh i i also want to
recognize that the department
you and the department have done a great
job under very difficult circumstances
and they
and to add that those claims that were
delayed were paid retroactively in full
so those people were made whole although
a little bit inconvenienced because of
the delay
quite understandable under the deluge
that you've experienced
so my it appears as though with the
state with the state part and
perhaps even with the federal as long as
you were not at fault if you didn't give
improper information
inaccurate information you're going to
be okay is that correct
yeah i think i think that's an accurate
statement
you know what happens next is determined
by uh
which program from which you were
overpaid um
easy if you were from state ui we
forgive it in that determination
if it's from and in most of these cases
it's not just state ui because in most
weeks you also had that federal
enhancement
in play as well so the federal portion
of it is
more complicated because of that waiver
process but at the end of the day
it should be the same result an
individual overpaid from a state program
versus an individual overpaid from a
federal program
if they are not at fault the end result
should be the same
and they are not required to make
restitution to the state
um i think it's um just how i go about
overseeing this part of the process i
think it's inherently
unfair to require someone not at fault
in um an overpayment uh being created
to then be expected to repay that they
didn't do anything
the agency made an error they
received dollars to which they felt and
and
thought they were eligible
it's just it's unfortunate that the
process for waiving those
for the federal portion um requires
additional steps on the part of the
individual
if there was a way of avoiding that i
would
jump all over it and there's not
so we're doing the best we can with the
rules that
have been uh provided to us by the feds
and we'll we'll move those as quickly as
we can and we've been
trying to make information available to
those individuals so that they know once
they submit a waiver request
you know we acknowledge receipt of it we
tell them we're reviewing it we'll be
getting a decision out to them
they're not responsible for making
payment um during that time period so we
try to be clear
with that information that we put out to
them and we've had that type of
information
out to the public since november of 2020
just letting them know that they're
that in a waiver situation that it's
being taken and that's under
consideration
don't you don't have to do anything um
until you hear back from us
follow up mr chair voila thank you
uh in regards to the uh the gig workers
and other
self-employed and other you know
employers who are kind of
closed down or having difficulty
responding to your your questions about
claims uh
is that considered uh faults of the
the employee of the claimant if the
information didn't come back and then
you paid out several thousand dollars
and then you know maybe they hadn't
really misrepresented anything it's just
perhaps a misunderstanding or perhaps
their vacation pay was paid to them
in some cases they didn't understand
so if it's a situation where someone is
um
they're they are truthful to the
department on their initial filing
uh but because of information we
subsequently receive
from their employer that they're
determined to be overpaid that person
would be without
fault in creation of that overpayment
that would be
a combination of agency and employer
error
in that type of situation depending on
the timing of when the information came
in
but as long as the as long as the inform
as long as the person
was accurate and truthful with the
department
they wouldn't have a problem in that
type of situation
uh thanks very much okay i have
representative turcotte
followed by representative attitude
good morning um just one quick question
on your second to last slide
uh you list the statement was there that
22 states had depleted their trust fund
could you just send me a link to
whatever wherever you got that
information
or the list or whatever's easiest for
you
um the easiest thing representative i
could i can send you the link
but if um you if you just
did a quick google search on title 12
borrowing
and do roman numeral 12
title 12 borrowing it should bring you
right
to the page that lists
all of the borrowing from up through the
prior
day with each state how much they've
borrowed
how much they've been authorized to
borrow for the current month
perfect thank you but i'll send that
i'll send that link out to uh chairman
infantine as well so he can um
distribute it to all the members i think
thank you
from geneva thank you mr chairman um
back back in april of 2020
um while the department was seeing a
dramatically increased volume
um there was guidance that was put out
by then attorney general mcdonald
regarding um governor snyder's order
on uh a freeze of investments in
foreclosures
uh the attorney general's guidance
specified that at the conclusion of
the state of emergency which we thought
was going to be a lot sooner
uh that those rents and mortgages were
happening today to be
full and there was no protection for
those folks
uh was there any discussion between
that you're aware of uh between the
attorney general's office
the governor's office and the department
of labor
uh surrounding the backlog of claims
and how you know something like that a
massive
financial obligation like that might be
unattainable for folks that were still
waiting for claims
um so they're
um at no point in time have we had a
massive backlog
of claims we've had a high volume of
claims throughout
including obviously
april of 2020 but
i could go through the payment totals by
week
uh for that back then um and it would
show you that we were paying out a lot
of money
real fast um but with regard to your
question
um i did not have uh any conversation
with uh
then attorney general mcdonald or uh
with the governor with regard to that
measure no
the representative your question was did
you know any between
the governor's office attorney general
the department of labor this is
department employment security
so did you mean to say that yeah okay
all right and you have a follow-up yeah
um
would there be any obstacles that you
can think of
regarding permanently accepting health
really
to gain workers um in the face of
gig work becoming more popular
um so the question uh just to restate it
to make sure i have it correctly
so the question would be are there any
obstacles to extending
um unemployment eligibility for gig
workers is that correct
i know what a gig worker is it's a guy
that maybe worked for uber or something
like that just could someone tell me
what the acronym really means
does gig stand for something actually i
think it actually comes from
like back when musicians would play out
they say
okay it was just one or two nights
sorry commissioner i just wanted to
figure to figure out what the reading
and i didn't know what the heck it meant
so
all right um when we talk about gig
workers
for new hampshire we're talking about
non-covered employment
for the most part so
self-employed are part of that so
prior to the pandemic and the changes
that were made
only those individuals that were in
covered employment
so most w-2 employment would be
people that would be eligible for
receipt of unemployment benefits if they
had a qualifying separation and had
enough
earnings so the cares act expanded that
to both non-covered employment gig
workers and
self-employed so right now the program
under which self-employed and gig
workers are paid benefits is the
pandemic
unemployment assistance program or pua
that was the federal cares act
program that created it new hampshire
as in all other states signed a state
agreement
with the u.s department of labor to
participate
in that program as we did for the
federal extension as we did
for the f-puc program the federal
enhancement program
right now that program is scheduled to
continue
until september 4th that was the
continuation from the american rescue
plan
so new hampshire participates in that
program
by virtue of having signed the state
agreement
and it continues because of the american
rescue plan so those people
right now continue to receive benefits
through the pua program without a pua
program they would not be eligible for
benefits in state unemployment
no other questions here in the lob do i
see any hands online
see representative smith warden and did
i see sullivan again
representative no representative smith
followed by representative warden
thank you mr chairman um and i am so
grateful that we have you uh assistant
commissioner uh
levers it's been absolutely stunning
working with you
i'm very grateful you came here today to
give us the numbers they really
they really show what happened last year
uh 2020 was an amazing an amazing year
i'd just like to make sure that we get
copies of your slides please
and um i know that the calls that i
received for help
um all came early in the system when uh
your phone was just over overburdened um
the people working there were
overburdened
and the people i heard from had complex
issues and i'm sure that what happened
was the
easy to do simple process
was managed when it came to complex
issues they had to be thought through
and there just wasn't time but they've
all been taken care of and i am so
grateful
and really that's that's why i asked you
to come here today so i could
thank you in public thanks very much
thank you representative smith i think
we all feel the same same way
gilman's work representative warden
do i see any other hands okay my
questions regarding the appeals and
waivers and the backlog how many cases
do you have in backlog
i believe you said you can handle up to
about 500
cases per month now so what is the total
backlog
and how many cases i mean how many
months will it take you to work through
all those
and are the people who are waiting for
response being up
up being updated on a regular basis as
to how long they should expect to wait
for a response
thank you yeah so good questions
representative um so
um individuals upon the filing of a of a
of an appeal um they are immediately
notified
of uh you know acknowledging receipt of
the appeal that we will re
we are reviewing it as quickly as
possible who to contact if they have
questions
um so we we give them an immediate
acknowledgement
um the 500 plus that we have scheduled
per month right now
that is not our capacity it's where
we're at right now
um so we've increased our capacity with
the new hearing uh
hearing officers that we've brought on
um and then we will be further
increasing that capacity with the new
hampshire law firms that are going to be
brought on
as well so we'll be increasing that
monthly output
um with how many uh we're able to how
many hearings we're able to conduct
we have about 2500 appeals that have
been received acknowledged docketed
and are in the process of getting a date
these are all telephonic
appeal hearings those will be added to
may
june july probably some of those into
august
and then like the state did with its
vaccination system as they got more
capacity they bumped up appointments
we'll be doing the same as more law
firms come on um
we'll be increasing the or we'll be
bumping
up appeal hearings to be um earlier
uh right now um so um
in terms of uh appeal requests
um those go into for the for the
overwhelming majority of cases people
email our appeals inbox right when they
get their determination they see oh i
have 14 days this is how i can do it can
be u.s
mail or it can be email here's the email
address boom
i'm going to submit my appeal uh right
now we are reviewing appeal requests
that came in
in the first half of march um and
so here we are um at the beginning of
may
um that is uh that's the backlog that i
had spoken about that we are going
through about 3 000 plus
pieces of correspondence a week right
now with the 20 additional people we
brought on from our vendor that supports
our hotline
so that's actually um that's going uh
that's ramped up real fast since we've
brought those people on so we're
we'll be through uh march i would say
within
probably another week to week and a half
and we'll be moving into april
um and those hearings are getting um
they're getting back filled into may
june um
um july then we'll be into august
um and then our effort will be to try to
move those up
that uh get pushed out initially when we
bring on more law firms to supplement
hearing officers
then those hearings are going to get
moved up as quickly as we can
while those people have a pending appeal
they are notified
by the department both on our website
and with
information that's sent out to them in
the determination
that if there's an overpayment that is
that's associated with that they're not
responsible for the overpayment while
their appeal is pending
um we had initially um we had
systems in place uh that were not very
easily to shut off or to change with
regard to interest accrual
things of that nature and so initially
what we told people
despite what you might have read in the
union leader today um
what we told people back in november of
um you know in a real hidden spot right
front and center on our website
we told them we said hey ignore any
determination
that you get regarding your overpayment
if you have an appeal pending including
interest
because we didn't want them to think
that we were requiring them to repay
while their appeal was pending so we put
that information out in november
of 2020 we've since shut that off
it took a little while to get the
programming
changed correctly without screwing other
things up
but we have that shut off right now so
that
individuals including people that don't
even file an appeal
right now they're not getting a
a demand notice they're not getting a
monthly billing statement
from us because we want to get through
the
backlog of appeals before we turn that
functionality back on
so we've tried to be real open and
transparent
since november of last year with regard
to that so people don't think we're
pursuing collection or
having their debt accrue interest while
they have an appeal pending
all right thank you representative
cahill thank you again mr chairman mr
lavis uh so
i just wanted to refer to uh my
colleagues earlier question about the
gig workers
and the issue there is that uh if you're
a gig
worker uh either self-employed or for
uber or door dash or some of the like uh
no one's paying in
into the system is that not correct
correct so they're they're they do not
have eligibility
under state ui um
and so they only have eligibility right
now under federal pua which is 100
percent paid
by the federal government if uh pua were
gone
um if that program were to go away those
individuals would not have eligibility
in
the state ui system because the trust
fund is made up of tax payments
from uh covered employers
and those the dollars that they pay in
in taxes are the dollars that we pay out
and benefits
and self-employed individuals have never
been eligible for unemployment benefits
in new hampshire
until this pandemic and once the pua
program goes away
they would lose eligibility under
current policy
unless obviously the legislature
made a change to that policy in terms of
who's eligible and
and who is not thank you
mr bishop i have a few questions
i know some of these things mr chairman
representative
no i did not i apologize replied
representative avellini evolani would
you have a question for the
commissioner i do mr i do mr chairman
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
lavish for being here with us today
um i want to thank you for your help and
support um
for some of the local businesses that we
had that were having issues with their
unemployment
their employees so again thank you for
all that assistance you gave us
um during this troubling time um the
question
i have and i'm sure the chairman will
cover some of them that i have as well
um is when will the trust fund be
replenished to
be 300 million at the current rates that
the employers are paying
um so i'll i'll caution uh too much
reliance
on what i'm going to say about the trust
fund forecast because
our experience over the course of the
last year
really makes you question
any type of forecast that goes beyond
certainly anything beyond a year
is tough in terms of a reliability index
so
right now we're forecasting as i showed
earlier the trust fund to
end 2021 in the range
of between 65 million to 84 million good
news is that we remain solvent without
borrowing
bad news is that we're only at 65 to 84
million
at the end of 2021. um we are
we are anticipating further growth in
the fund in 2022
based upon the additional
hiring that we expect to take place um
and less reliance on less reliance by
individuals
for unemployment benefit payments those
numbers have been coming down
week to week like i said before we have
about 19 000 people that are currently
filing
in the state ui program um
in terms of a longer range forecast and
the when to expect the fund
to next uh to be at that 250 million
dollar level which triggers the first
rate reduction to employers i think
we're looking at uh
probably about three years uh before the
fund is able to grow
back up to that point and then
in order to then achieve the additional
solvency
thresholds of 275 and 300
you could be looking at upwards of five
years but again
a lot of question marks there um with
regard to the
the uh type of growth that we see
um following um the dramatic
loss of uh large segment of our labor
force during the pandemic
so it will all be determined by how
quickly
new hampshire continues to recover
thank you my recollection the last time
unfortunately i was here
through this it did take five years i
understand we're only
um employers are only paying tax on the
first fourteen thousand dollars
of the individual's wage so it takes a
while to catch up
once that that's why the first quarter
of every year
is the biggest revenue uh income period
for the department after that when
people reach that 14
000 they're no longer paying the
unemployment tax so the second third and
fourth quarters
money usually goes out more than it
comes in it takes a while to catch up
um the questions i have for you um mr
commissioner are some things we've
already discussed but i think it's
important for
people who are listening either online
or here in the committee
one of the scenarios that occurred he
had two individuals not getting along
very well
in one employer and the employer tried
to deal with that
the one of the employees quit uh their
job
and then filed for unemployment received
the unemployment the owner
was shocked because well i have a job
for you and you have to
be available to have a job and i have
the job
why are you paying him unemployment that
really had to do with
federal money because the individual
could claim that they had to stay home
to take care of their children and such
that
the employer was not going to be charged
for unemployment on their tax rate for
that individual
is that an accurate portrayal of that
of what go what goes on in that
circumstance yes
that's uh you've what you've said is
very much accurate so
because of the pua program someone
could have been offered suitable
employment but
they qualified for pua because of one of
those cares act related reasons in your
scenario it was to care for a remote
learner
that's largely gone right now
with the governor's requirement for
in-person learning effective back as of
april 19th
so that population of people that are
filing under pua because they are the
primary caregiver for
a student whose school is closed
uh schools are open um and we've been
providing that information
to individuals that have been certifying
to that reason
they've been receiving quite a bit of
information from us
again trying to achieve compliance
through education
and we've been reminding them the
guard rails of that type of eligibility
but once you're once the school is open
that is
no longer an area of eligibility for
someone under pua
they could have other eligibility but
that would be
some that would not be the reason they
would now qualify for pua
since that job is still open and i
believe it's the 23rd of this month
individuals receiving unemployment are
now going to be required again to go
look
for um a job and considering
we have people begging for workers in
many of the service industries
do you expect that as of that
23rd date if i have the correct date may
23rd
there will be more people coming in to
be available for employment
i i hope so um you know it's
we we turned off the work search
requirement for a year
um feels like a lot longer than that um
what i mean work search is a fundamental
pillar of the unemployment program
i want to deal with you for as short a
duration as possible i want to get you
back
to work our re-employment services
bureau is
a critical component of what the
department is all about
and i'm excited to get back to a point
where we can really be
helping individuals take advantage of
the amount of opportunity that is
out there with it seems like every
business
that i drive by is hiring right now we
had a job fair
three weeks ago virtual job fair for
seacoast and southern tier employers 100
employers
3 400 openings 138 people showed up to
look for work
that that's not sustainable it's not
healthy
it's not good i'm not doing the
individual a favor
by allowing them to easily continue to
connect collect
unemployment long-term unemployment's
not good for the individual or the
economy
so getting back to having a work search
requirement
where they're they're not being required
to start
working they're being required to start
looking
and to participate in activities and
make contacts with hiring employers
so that they can get back into suitable
employment we're going to be doing a lot
to educate
people in the unemployment system over
the next few weeks
every single one of them is going to be
scheduled for a virtual and
or virtual workshop where we're going to
take about a half an hour review
work search requirements going to go
over the screens that they're going to
be seeing again
explaining to them what uh con the
employment contacts look like what act
what types of activities
qualify make sure they understand about
all of the 10 virtual job fairs that we
have over the course of this month that
is going to cover every single part of
our state
with hiring employers being able to
showcase their positions to
people that now have a work search
requirement so we're going to be showing
them
and going over all of the tools our
offices are going to be back open as of
this coming monday
where we can people can come in and use
our computers and our resource centers
to search for work
but it's it's really getting back to the
way that the unemployment program is
intended to function
states were prior to the pandemic states
were measured against one another
as to who had the shortest duration of
unemployment um
and and that's because we're a
short-term
temporary financial bridge to get
someone back to work
and that's what we're going to get back
to doing and uh i'm excited to be able
to start working with people again and
i'll be out in all of our offices
starting next week um so that we can
effectively and safely
uh work with with the public again
a few more quick ones you mentioned in
your testimony or your discussion
that you waived the requirement for
non-profits to reimburse
um unemployment which they would
normally have to do was that the same
for municipalities or was that just for
the non-profits
it was the same for municipalities as
well okay
thank you when you talked about the
hearings that you're having uh
kind of what representative warden
talked about if there's 8 000 out there
right now you're only doing 500 a month
you know that would take you know 16
months to take care of obviously you're
hiring more individuals how many of
these hearings are
for oh this ballpark
overpayment versus denied
currently denied for new um
[Music]
people requesting yeah i would i would
say the um
um it's an important distinction they
make because some of these are people
that just denied and they disagree with
the denial
um rather than give you a figure that
i'm not entirely positive about
um let me get back to you on that and
give you a rough breakdown
of that um one just one quick thing on
that mr chairman
um there's a tremendous increase in the
number of people using the unemployment
system
and people that receive determinations
that they don't agree with they then
file an appeal so the number of people
has caused a spike in the number of
appeals being filed
but one thing that gets overlooked
that's also
increased the amount of appeals being
filed is
these federal programs require us to
issue more determinations per person
so before someone can get put on federal
pua
we have to issue them a determination
denying them state ui
some people they don't quite understand
um how that process works we've tried to
explain it they file an appeal
of that those appeal requests then have
to get reviewed they then have to get
scheduled
might not be intentional the person
might have already moved on to pua but
it takes time to review all that
it bogs things down so there's a lot of
extra determinations that we have to
issue
on each of these claims which also
increases that claim load and that
appeals load
my point mr was that hopefully um
more deference to those that are denied
that are looking for unemployment versus
the ones that were
trying for the repayments for um which
you know obviously one is more urgent
than the other the the
the next round the next question i have
really has to do with this repayment
it's clear from hearing you today that
we have the state amount and then we
have the federal amount
and we have these individuals who um 8
000 individuals
you feel um it is not their fault why
they were overpaid
so the situation that has been brought
to my attention as an individual
uh had a hearing uh was determined he
was
uh it was not his fault he was overpaid
he had to provide
the federal affidavit individuals like
why do i have to
provide the affidavit you already said i
i don't uh
it's not my fault so then um
in the meantime he is still on
unemployment a certain amount was taken
out of his unemployment check this week
to still pay it off even though it was
waived
so obviously that's from the federal
part and
so you have to take care of both the
state part
and the federal part you make one
determination from the state
based on your own set of rules then you
have to follow the federal set of rules
to be able to waive that part and while
you're waiting for that
the state still has the ability to try
to collect some of that money back
from so in the in the situation uh mr
chairman
with someone that i think you described
someone who had had had their appeal
hearing and they were determined to be
without fault
right that person um unless there's
another overpayment
uh you know maybe a pre-existing
overpayment from prior to the pandemic
or something else going on
they shouldn't have their benefits being
offset
um in fact i'm more than happy
if you could send that one to me so i
can look at because we've actually shut
off
our offset capability right now
however even if we hadn't shut off the
offset capability
every individual when they receive the
determination
that finds them overpaid in that
there are instructions explaining to
them
that if they don't appeal and they
continue to file
that their future payments could be
offset to repay their debt and if they
would like to avoid that
they're given instruction right there
right in that decision saying
contact this number and they will work
with you on establishing a payment
agreement that
is consistent with your current
financial ability to pay
so it's always a situation that can be
avoided
we've currently shut off our offset
functionality
right now but as long as someone reaches
out
and follows that instruction on the
determination
they should not be having that a large
portion of their unemployment benefit
offset to repay a debt i will get that
information over to you the last thing i
would request but
if you would send along also a copy of
your powerpoint presentation that you
presented to us so i can get it to the
rest of the committee
there are a lot of good helpful numbers
that we can share with our constituents
i want to keep within the noon time here
i am
finished with my questions uh any other
questions here in the llb
seeing on any online and last final
questions for the commissioner
all right well thank you very much um uh
mr commissioner we appreciate it uh
we uh we all think you're doing a very
good job
uh the fact that you're you're very
polite you said 97 was 97.6 some people
would
some people would round that up to 98 so
appreciate your
appreciate your candor um and um
and the fact that you are trying
the best you can to get additional
employees
or law firms in to the department to
help with these um
overpayments one of the only other
things um
something i would ask you to work on and
i understand you're doing the best you
can
one of the complaints i had is that
sometimes very difficult to get through
on the telephone
and talk to someone that knows what
they're doing um
or at least i i take that back that was
incorrectly stated getting to the right
person for their issue
um is it easier and
more efficient for you folks if they
email versus call in
um the call-in is still the best way the
way that the hotline currently works
is we have it's a tiered structure i'll
be i'll be brief with this mr chairman
um we have a vendor on on tier one that
all the calls
go into or the or the lion's share of
the calls go into
they've been skilled and trained on how
to handle most
uh basic unemployment related questions
uh we give them
weekly sometimes daily training on
current hot topics and what we see for
uh topics for uh that are causing a
spike in calls
if they cannot handle it they then
transfer it immediately to tier two
tier two or department employees these
are all of our staff
in the local offices that are spending
their days
on the phone answering questions so
we have about ten thousand calls a week
right now that we're receiving
um four to five thousand of those end up
getting
transferred in and handled by our local
office staff
so um that's the best route for getting
a question with regard to your
eligibility answered
now what i've found because a few people
have my email address
it tends to get plastered all over
social media
i can't keep my voicemail
down to a number that i you can leave a
message um
when uh those people that they complain
to me about the hotline it's not that
they haven't been able to get an answer
they don't like the answer that they've
gotten
and so sometimes i'll be the first to
admit
the the vendor staff that we have who
have been quickly trained up
sometimes their the answer they provide
could have been better
and the person is rightfully agitated
by the lack of being able to get the
answer they need
other times it's they the answer that
they got is not the one they wanted
and that's important to remember
excellent well thank you very much um
we appreciate that you have a great day
commissioner
members of the labor committee we will
resume at one o'clock for
house senate bill 137 and 2 o'clock for
house
senate bill 123 we'll keep the zoom on
and the volume off here in the lob
and we'll see you in about an hour enjoy
your
your lunch thank you everyone for
[Music]
participating
um
is
ah
let's see
is the ball you want can everybody hear
us online
yes okay there have been an announcement
uh made by christina dyer
that we did not have um
a live capabilities to listen to
our first part of our hearing
on uh youtube i did receive a text about
10 minutes into
the discussion with the commissioner
that we did have that access back so in
case anyone was wondering it would only
we were having technical problems but
that was resolved
pretty quickly so is everyone
here we've got uh one minute christina
uh there is a gentleman a lobbyist
who forgot to sign up who will
be raising his hand
uh because at this point i have seven
individuals
that have signed a custom life so far
[Music]
okay great thank you
it is now one o'clock
sorry you're all set yeah i am now
all right excellent it is now one
o'clock we are going to open this
hearing the house uh labor committee
hearing on
senate bill 137 relative to the minimum
hourly
rate for tipped employees
and i
have some representatives and senators
listed
so christina can you let me know who is
who's online
senator bradley representative horgan
representative horrigan is here uh we
have alicia preston
curtis berry heather goalie henry villa
catherine cummings representative chris
schultz
rick newman and rudolph alden
okay i think i know everybody there but
i don't have a
presenter for the bill
so um i would
senator pardon i'm
well i'm going to um i'm going to punt
here
would any of you like to representative
see with would you please
introduce house bill 137 for senator
bradley
i would be happy to uh representative
brian seaworth from pembroke
representing the district that is
pembroken
chichester and i
would like to introduce senate bill 137
relative to the minimum hourly rate for
tipped employees
thank you very much
thanks from a standpoint of
representatives is representative
timothy horgan representative you're
recognized to speak
okay i'm uh i was i'm surprised that i'm
the first one
speaking um but i'm i'm opposed to
senate bill 137
for the simple reason that it uh lowers
the min
the wage for tips employees who are
often um
we found out how valuable they are
during the pandemic which is still going
on
but uh you know they're they're
underpaid they're overworked they're
underappreciated and this just pays them
pays them less and then also the whole
uh you know because it's 327 an hour
basically um senator bradley is not here
to explain why he did it but
that is about 45
of uh current 725 and certainly
i assume this is going to assume this is
in anticipation
of the possibility that the federal
minimum wage which is also our state
minimum wage will be uh
will be will be increased um so that's
uh
and also like probably think a lot of
the other things in rsa279
21 need to be changed but this bill just
affects that one thing so i think that's
uh not a good change if you're gonna
change it at all
the uh base rate should be higher in
fact it probably
should just be the federal minimum wage
and then the tips are on top of that so
i
think that uh with the tips um
i think basically the way it works the
base wage is what the uh
but the owner of the restaurant or the
other facility
pays you to be there even if there's no
customers there and then um
the tips are on top of that are for
providing
the service for the employees and it's
kind of a strange way
to compensate people but that's what
evolved and um
some ways i'm glad to do it because at
least i can uh
i can make sure they're paid leaves a
little bit more than the uh
the absolute minimum so that's uh i mean
i do understand the uh
the tourist industry is a key industry
in our country in our especially
in our country in our state but actually
uh they're having trouble finding
employees one is it maybe because the
pay rates are are too low given the uh
what the labor market is like because
we're having um so i i
i stay this bill uh still
been i t owned in the past and um it
should be it'll begin so that's uh
that's basically all i have to say about
it i probably probably much more
go on more about the technical details
than i can but if you want to ask me a
question i'll know
you can do so thank you representative
any questions here in the lob
seeing none of any questions for the
representative online
i don't see any thank you representative
morgan well thank you
thank you senator um bradley is with us
senator
senator bradley
there you go sorry about that mr
chairman and i apologize for being
late um
so pleased to be here in support of uh
senate bill 137 which the senate passed
um this is a very simple bill and it's
also a very important bill
especially with the discussion in
washington about
raising the minimum wage to 15 an hour
while it hasn't happened yet uh
certainly
it could and there are a lot of people
pushing for it what that would mean
given our tying of the minimum wage
in new hampshire to the federal minimum
wage
would be nearly or actually more than a
doubling
of the current tipped wage to i believe
6.75
cents an hour um by virtue of the fact
that
we are tied at 45 to the minimum wage
i think we all are very very aware
of the duress and the ongoing pressure
that our hospitality industry and
particularly
restaurants are under and are going to
continue to be under
many of them have barely survived if
they've survived at all the pandemic
and the potential of more than
doubling the tipped wage
is something that could put many
restaurants
under the um just continued duress
and and caused them to fold there was a
lot of support
in the senate amongst the hospitality
industry
for this i think you will hear that
discussion
today from many of the same folks that
we heard the discussion the one um
thing that i would add mr chairman is
the contingency
section on line 19 and 20 of the bill
that this only takes effect
if the minimum wage is raised federally
so if nothing changes
nothing changes in new hampshire the
only other thing that i would add mr
chairman is
everybody knows that the vast majority
of a
tipped employee's salary comes from
tips not the minimum wage and so by
raising the cost
as this would do if the federal minimum
wage went up and new hampshire's law
was not changed would force
employers in the hospitality industry to
move
to more tablets replacing people
and downshift or reduce hours
reduce the number of shifts it would
probably lead to job loss and
there would not be a corresponding gain
for an awful lot of people
that could well find themselves out of
work if
this happens raising the minimum wage as
i've always said is well intended but it
has
that consequence of job loss we want to
make sure that
our hard-working restaurant owners
are able to survive this pandemic and
survive
a doubling of the minimum wage without
the tipped wage in new hampshire going
up so
i support the bill obviously and happy
to answer your questions
thank you senator bradley questions in
the lob robertson vatican
thank you mr chairman um thank you
senator bradley i would
beg your patience as i have a couple
questions to go for you
um i'm looking at line nine
uh in bill tipton
line eight to nine tips employees were
licensed as secondary game operators
pursuant to rsa 2017
um uh would receive a base rate from the
employer not less than 7.25 an hour
um could you define
um what a secondary game operator
pursuant to that rsa is and why
the senate felt an appropriate intimate
a special part of that
in this legislation so we
made that addition to the legislation
as a result of
the secondary game operators coming to
us
and saying they had tipped employees
that would be subject to the
minimum wage increase so we added that
in
per their request since they are also
tipped wages we did the same with cigar
bars
again um the same rationale
thank you i understand including them
um but it seems like based on the
language they would be making
more um securely
uh without the compensation tips than
they would
uh were they restaurant burgers is that
not the case
i'm sure that um somebody representing
the secondary game operators and the
cigar bars will testify
um and i guess i'd ask you to ask them
that question
follow up um you mentioned in
your testimony of the potential
downsides to
increasing the minimum wage
would have on restaurant employment um
however a study from the economic policy
institute suggested that
the seven states that don't have a
separate tip to minimum wage
are all currently experiencing higher
restaurant growth rates
and have the same higher rates of
tipping as the states with a sub minimum
wage
do you feel that's accurate or no so i
think that um the senate heard testimony
and you certainly can pull up the
hearing report
um and i suspect you'll hear testimony
today
from restaurant owners i mean that's
you know the most accurate summation i
think of
what they're feeling and what they're
facing if the minimum wage increases and
so
the senate uh wanting to protect them
and protect those jobs and to try to
keep them viable
that's why we passed this bill
one last follow-up thank you mr chairman
um
again looking at the bill uh reading
from line
15 uh if an employee shows the
satisfaction commissioner that the
actual amount of wages received at the
end of the pay period did not equal the
minimum wage for all hours work
the employer shall pay the employee the
difference to guarantee the applicable
minimum wage
given that new hampshire doesn't have
its own minimum wage
the supremacy laws the constitution
defers that we follow to
the 725 minimum wage
is an employer not just making up the
difference between
the tips and 15
an hour regardless of what the base
minimum wage is set at
because it just feels it just feels like
it's the same amount of money
and the employee would be making that
closer to 15
an hour anyways and this just feels like
a very
hat on a hat kind of retracted well
first of all representative lines 15
through 18
are existing statutes so um
this isn't changing that
understood
i guess that's
uh it here at llp uh
followed by turcotte
oh you're recognized thank you mr chair
um
senator bradley uh thank you for coming
today
just have a couple questions just for my
own edification
uh in your testimony mentioned um
that if the minimum wage which we follow
is federal um where it were to go up and
double that you know
potential job loss uh potential uh
businesses would be under a hardship
would be uh
hard to maintain costs
might even put them out of business my
question
is
that would occur to all businesses
so why is this bill singling out a
certain
subgroup of people to protect
well the reason for that representative
is that
our statute in new hampshire ties
the minimum wage for tipped employees
to 45 percent of the applicable
minimum wage so my understanding
is the federal
tipped minimum wage is actually below
our 327 mark now if the federal
if congress also raises the minimum
tipped wage federally then obviously
that would supersede new hampshire law
but if it leaves it alone the fact that
our 45 percent
of whatever the federal minimum wage
uh would more than double it so that's
why
the carve out obviously you know there's
been a debate
for many years in new hampshire about
raising
the minimum wage and as i think i
indicated before it is well intended
some people benefit but then especially
entry-level workers first-time job
seekers
who need that first job may get priced
out
of that first job with an increase in
the minimum wage
but that's a different debate
that's a debate about the overall
minimum wage this
is just about tipped employees
remembering the vast majority of a
tipped
um employee's salary should be from tips
not you know the stipend that they're
paid and
but at the same time the cost to
restaurant tours
by doubling that is going to lead to
price increases
perhaps less tips less jobs
and an overall problem i think
for the restaurant industry in new
hampshire
and that's why you know this is a narrow
bill not a broad bill on the minimum
wage it's
specific because new hampshire has that
45 percent
um you know tying to the federal minimum
wage
thank you representative turcotte
followed by representatives
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
bradley uh one question
on uh beginning online 11 and going to
14 there's a
paragraph that starts with if such an
employee shows the satisfaction
on and on and on uh further down in line
14 through 18 there seems to be almost
duplicative
uh wording can you explain
is there a difference there honestly
i've read through that about 10 times
and i'm trying to figure out
why that both those uh paragraphs are
there
i'm sure i'm looking at it too
so i know that in the senate
test uh hearing um
there was testimony from the department
of labor sorry to deflect that question
but
um it might be better to ask
the department would you repeat that
i i don't follow you representative line
if you start on uh line 11 mr chairman
where it says
if such an employer shows to the
satisfaction
and that continues in bold through line
four it does look to be the exact same
language
there's a very very very slight
difference but to me the intent is
the same so i'm trying to figure out if
there was
actually an intent or if it's a drafting
error or just
it just doesn't look right to me uh
going further mr chairman on line
14 at the very end it starts again
if an employee shows to the satisfaction
on and on and on
and again other than i don't even
remember
one or two minimum one or two word
differences it's the exact same
intent i believe but i must have the
wrong i'm looking at
uh amendment to senate bill 137
amendment 2021-0983
s correct
okay i want to make sure we're actually
i think what we should be looking at is
uh
sp 137 as a i think that's probably
represented
i i didn't hear what you said
representative sullivan
i'm looking at sp 137 as amended by the
senate i'm not looking at it
okay and i think perhaps i'm guessing
that when the amendment was incorporated
into the bill
as amended it was done in property
i'm guessing also but again as written
it doesn't appear
correct so all right we will
thank you yeah mr chairman this is uh
jeb again
i think uh the questioner is correct
um it appears to be a drafting error but
um i trust you folks to sort that out
trust thank you yes trust
representative seawork thank you mr
chairman and thank you senator
this may be another one you that's worth
deferring
uh to someone later my question
is also on line 11 but
the first part of that line where
and in some of the testimony we talked
about
what the different minimum wages would
be for tipped employees
um this seems to introduce a new one
at 7.25 an hour that is neither
45 of the new one nor is it the old one
and it again it seems strange to me
for the particular class of secondary
game operators
to introduce a minimum wage that doesn't
match any of the others
so from the standpoint of the senate
amendment
is there an intent there that we should
be aware of
or is that something i should bring up
with uh
you'd probably be best advised to bring
that up with the
representatives of the tipped employees
for
secondary game operators because this
was the language that they
asked us to insert and it may be
pursuant to the existing rsas
all right
all right that's all the questions here
in the llb the questions online
please anyone
representative bouchard be recognized
uh thank you mr chair and thank you
senator
for taking my question um
senator had have you seen the studies
that are out there
that show that when you increase wages
that you increase the productivity of
the employees
and you lower the turnover rate which is
a
very big cost to an awful lot of
restaurants to be able to train
employees
uh thank you for taking my question so
i'm sure that if the
uh restaurant owners thought it was in
their best interest
financially they would
raise that tipped wage themselves
that being said certainly the testimony
in the senate revolved around you know
the financial duress that would put many
restaurant owners
under given the vagaries and the
pressures that they've faced through the
pandemic
and the fact that even as
you know people are starting to get
vaccinated and go back to restaurants
now
it's still a diminished diminished
capacity
um you know in their business it may
change
but i think they feel the duress and
they've been under that duress for a
long time and so
um i think the senate took that
testimony seriously
given the pressure that restaurants are
under
thank you senator
thank you um any other questions online
representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
senator bradley uh
i know you're you've expressed a concern
that if the wage the federal wage goes
to fifteen dollars
that it would double the uh tipped rate
uh it may be unlikely it may only go to
eleven or twelve do you have a
contingency for
that would would it not be more in line
more reasonable to have
if it went to 12 it would be like 5 and
40 cents an hour
and again this is only paid it's only
making up the difference when the tips
were so
which we're told the tips are twenty
dollars an hour it's only when the tips
aren't twenty dollars an hour but the
employer has to make up the difference
would would that be reasonable to havoc
uh
maybe i know that there was a bill to
lower the percentage uh
you know in the event middle business
can be scaled down a bit
um there's you know in my view
i mean obviously it would have less of
an impact
on a restaurant owner but
just reading the tea leaves
i think the pressure is on
to raise the minimum wage to at least 15
an hour
and there's as much pressure to raise it
higher than fifteen dollars an hour in
washington
as there is to be somewhere between
seven twenty five and fifteen
so what happens who knows regardless
tipped employees you know while this
you could argue would benefit them
even if the minimum wage say went to 12
not 15
and their percentage went to about six
dollars as opposed to 6.75
it still would be a big cost on
restaurants and
i think what you'd see is the
corresponding move to
you know reduce shifts reduce hours
and use technology whenever possible to
replace
um wait staff and and you know we've
certainly seen that
in areas of the country that have um
raised the minimum wage significantly
some people have been helped
no question about it if you're somebody
that
you know has a job and your wage has
gone up
as a result of the change in law more
power to you but if you're somebody who
has lost their job because they've been
priced out of the market or you're a
first-time
job seeker that is suddenly priced out
of the market
they're losers too and i think
that's always been my concern with
raising the minimum wage
i mean as as i think we all know right
now
um there are thousands of jobs
um available in new hampshire and so
anybody that wants to work
can work but restaurants are under
undue pressure because of the pandemic
that
is going to be with us i think for quite
some time
and the potential of this burden on
restaurants
i think when you hear their testimony i
hope you feel compelled as we were in
the senate
knowing that you know lions 19 and 20
the contingency language nothing changes
in new hampshire
unless the minimum wage increases in
washington
thank you senator so this is will
infant time uh i was reading the senate
testimony
are we the only state in new england
that has a
tipped wage that has a percentage of the
the minimum
i i'm not certain of that but i believe
that to be the case
thank you representative adagent you
have another question for the senator
uh thank you senator for taking the
question um as
was pointed out correctly by
representatives
out there uh regarding turnover
and uh savings from that in the
restaurant industry in fact
one that i'm going to i'm going to stop
ask a question
please i'd like to have a lot of
latitude on this representative over the
last couple of weeks
please ask a question instead of making
making your point
of what you want to get in there and
then asking the question off that please
uh would you believe that there are
robust studies of employment
in restaurants regarding minimum wage
increases then they suggest that wage
increases get absorbed by
price increases that do not impact point
of order
this was specifically brought up by the
clerk of the house
that the use of would you believes
are not appropriate in hearings the
purpose of hearings
are to receive testimony and ask
questions
of that testimony what you believe is
making a comment made in the statement
to the individual
that the individual wants to get out
there this is
this the the line that uh representative
adjutant has taken
is not appropriate for this senate
understood
thank you that was what was presented by
the clerk please ask your question
but definitely please okay i was not
aware of that
so i'll take that into consideration um
i want you to ask your question
representative i just want you to do it
in a way that's
acceptable thank you senator bradley
do you believe
that there might be a difference
between what is most beneficial
in the best interest of a restaurant
worker
versus the interest of the restaurant
well i think as i've tried to answer
this question
the minimum wage creates winners and
losers
and if your wage goes up you're clearly
a winner
but if you've lost your job due to
technology
or less hours or fewer shifts
because the cost to the restaurant owner
that creates losers too
and so i've always been very concerned
that raising the minimum wage and while
this is a subset of it
does create winners and losers and in
particular
and restaurants are really good at
hiring
first-time job seekers
i mean that that is a staple for many
restaurants and they are
often at tipped wages and
if they're unable to hire as many people
then people lose too and that's my
concern
thank you one more question
representative
thank you mr chairman uh senator this is
just
i just want to be clear on on
state and federal it's my understanding
that new hampshire defers basically to
the federal
minimum wage as we don't have a statute
defining the federal
defining our own minimum wage in this
bill there are there is a number
proposed
as opposed to a percentage which
effectively would freeze
that minimum wage my question is is how
does that play out
um can the state of new hampshire
supersede
federal or can or does federal supersede
state well i think i
answered that if the feds raised the
tipped minimum wage
then this debate is over but
in the past my understanding
representative
is congress has raised the minimum
wage without raising the tipped wage so
this bill only applies to that
circumstance
where congress were to raise the minimum
wage
and leave the tipped wage unadjusted but
because of the 45
provision in new hampshire law then
our minimum wage in that eventuality
would more than double if the feds
raised the tip minimum wage
this debate is over they raised
thank you senator
see no other hands senator bradley thank
you for your testimony
thank you very much mr chairman and
again i apologize for being late
no worries next up is representative
tony kaplan
merrimack district six representative
are you with us
i do not see him let me know uh via text
if he comes back on please
um the next step is henry value new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
mr value
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
for the record my name is henry value
and i'm here on behalf of the lodging
and restaurant association
uh we asked uh senator bradley uh
to bring this bill in um and it is